hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
here's a tremendous logic puzzle
after a church service a priest and a
cantor had a conversation
the priest asked
do you know the ages of the three
visitors we had today
the cantor said
i do not know
the priest said
what if i told you the product of their
ages is 2450.
the cantor did some calculations and
then replied i still don't know
the priest said
interestingly the sum of their ages is
two times your age
the cantor thought about it and said
there is still not enough information
the priest then said
as you remember i did not eat cake at my
birthday party choosing to be healthier
i wonder if the three people who came
today will stop eating cake when they
reach my age
the cantor then said
now i know their ages
the puzzle is
how old is the priest
i thank peter for sending me this puzzle
this is one of the most fun puzzles of
its kind and i highly encourage you
to work through all of the possibilities
and try and figure it out
you can logically solve for the age of
the priest
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
[Music]
so how can we figure out how old the
priest is
we'll start with the first clue that the
product of their ages is 2450
it will help us to consider the prime
factorization of 2450 which is two times
five squared times seven squared
now we need to find three numbers whose
product is twenty four fifty
we'll work through this on a case
case-by-case basis
one case is if we have two factors that
are equal to one
the only way this can happen is if the
third factor is twenty four fifty
another case is where we have a single
factor that's equal to one
for the other two numbers
one number will be a factor of 2450 say
x
and then the other will be the other
factor that pairs with it which is 2450
divided by x
now from the prime factorization we can
easily figure out each of the factors
and its pair
and we can enumerate these possibilities
so these are some of the possibilities
to get the rest we consider the third
case where we work through that the
smallest factor is equal to two
then we work through the possibilities
when the smallest factor is equal to
five and then we work through all the
possibilities where the smallest factor
is equal to seven
this will be all of the rest of the
cases
so this will take some effort but you
can figure out that these are the only
possibilities
now to be sure you can check all of the
cases with the computer program too
in wolfram alpha for example you can put
in the following syntax
that way you can check that these are
all of the cases
so now what can we do from here
the next clue is that the sum of their
ages is two times the cantor's age
so we'll consider the sums of each of
these triplets
now it'll take some effort but we can
systematically figure out what each
triplet adds up to
at this point the cantor says there's
still not enough information
if the sum uniquely identified a triplet
the cantor would know
which sum led to which ages
thus the sum must not uniquely identify
a triplet and must correspond to two
cases
now out of these possibilities
only the sum of 64 corresponds to two
different cases
so the sum must be equal to 64.
so there are two possibilities for the
ages
now for the final clue the priest says
something about his birthday party and
that he didn't eat cake
but he wonders if the three people who
came will stop eating cake when they
reach his age
suddenly the cantor knows the ages of
the three people
the implication is that the cantor knows
the priest's age and the priest is older
than the three visitors
if the priest was 51 or older then the
cantor could not deduce anything
but since the cantor could figure out
the ages it must have been that the
priest is 50 years old which eliminates
the 7750 case
therefore the visitors must be age 5 10
and 49 the cantor's age is half their
sum 64 divided by 2 which is equal to 32
and the priest's age is equal to 50.
and like magic we have figured out all
five ages
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video
these math videos which can be watched
for free inspire and build confidence
for people around the world and they
already have over a hundred million
views
with your help we can share the beauty
of mathematics and make the world a
better place
please subscribe for free to get the
newest videos
watch and share all of mine your
decisions videos
email me a puzzle or math topic presh
mindyourdecisions.com
and if you so choose
you can check out my books which are
linked in the video description and you
can support me on patreon to earn
exclusive rewards
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support